in all the ten years the hard work the
missing sleep braving traffic how did
you deal with the inertia that would set
in and the questions that would come up
and say is this really worth it so how
did you push her is it really worth you
know trying to succeed on the radio
beating my head up against the wall I
mean I did have to I did have that
moment where I said okay you know I have
to face reality here it might never
happen the way that I originally
envisioned it but let's take let's take
line back for example I mentioned your
mother you know you sad became a big
radio talk shows like him I know these
people personally same thing went for
dr. Laura use her as an example I see
the flip side I've seen the impact of
accomplishing the dream that kind of
goes back to what I said before about
your dream becoming a nightmare there's
a flip side and so when I saw that in
having that window in what would happen
if I already know that it's not what
it's cracked up to me does it have
benefits to have that huge platform that
use off huge audience you get your ideas
out there get your art out there it's a
great thing but there is that flip side
if in knowing that flip side help me to
reassess whether or not if whether or
not i should say you know what maybe
this is better off as a hobby because
he's i will do this with my brother too
he wanted to be a state cop more than
anything and I was one hundred percent
behind him but he accomplished that goal
it brought me to tears watching him up
on stage and you know get that edge into
his chest he got it he did it and I
remember a hardy work he went through
the Academy he gives a selection process
he had to go through in the first two
times it didn't work
third time he finally makes it to the
Academy he makes it through the Academy
and then after a little bit of time on
the road having to pick people's
children up off the road from a car rack
and having to go and tell that family
that their brother that they're you know
son is not coming home it was just too
much he said I can't do it his dream
became a nightmare for him and he said I
can't do this in so he hit you dad and
you know I always said don't know like
you know whatever things you have your
brother whatever you want to do behind
you a hundred percent and so he made
that announcement so you know there's a
perfect example and in radio it's the
same thing you know work hard all those
years and then you get a shot and you'll
get paid and there's no support and you
have to figure it out on your own and
yeah you just have to see you so it's
this prideful just make sense you know
and so great in the whole time always
have I always had my regular job and so
I always had want to come with it and
act as you could say okay well maybe I
could have focused more on that dream
but then you don't have forever don't
live your life like you got five more
waiting for you assume this is the only
one you've got and then that clock is
ticking one thing we have all old cop
one day we're not going to be here you
only have so much time spent it making
your life happy and if that makes you
happy then god bless you go for it but I
think that in the end of the day you
know chasing Fame is not a good plan do
what you love and if you can make money
at it and it does matter what you do if
you want to be a teacher be the best
friggin teacher on the planet but don't
don't kind of walk through life you know
figuring out well I'll just go through
the motions in is one day who it's all
gone
so do what makes you happy and in my
particular case who was living a certain
lifestyle being able to afford things
being able to fix problems and it for me
that's why it couldn't be the starving
artist because for me true happiness in
freedom and independence is what I
wanted and so I know that if I hit a
certain income level that when if
something came up on my wife's car was
toast I didn't have to sit there and
figure out oh my god what am I gonna do
I said get rid of it catch a car now
Brandon I can't just fine self hard like
that I'm not at that level but it's just
the ability to fix palms my washer was
broken you know fix it and that freedom
that independence to solve problems
within my own life that matters to me it
doesn't matter what everyone some people
don't don't care about that you got to
make that decision for yourself but in
my case that was really important
you